monter sûr que ça t'embête pas combien
de temps d'ailleurs avec lola c est
pourquoi j super idée j'ai filmé toutes
les vacances comme ça tu sais ce qu'on
leur a fait je vais te montrer la forêt
la tour est conçu à trois endroits
on a retrouvé votre fille les sénateurs
coeur sol il rappelé c'est certain elle
parle pas c'est important là il faut que
tu me pas pourquoi tu t'appelles 2000
syndicale reparlera quand elle sera en
confiance et si bonne traversée
pour elle est super comme ça ton père il
a tort que je la fasse tout elle quelque
chose jamais dû faire ça
pour coter sa lola ray pour moi tu m'as
dit qu'elle savait maman mais qu'est ce
qu'elle sait arrête calme-toi cana il ya
tout ça prouve que tout va bien dit
tarifs et dollars
ce papa continue tu pourrais faire corps
que ta joie
j'ai envie de vivre